le chatelier's principle says if a
stress is applied to a reaction at
equilibrium
the net reaction goes in the direction
that relieves the stress
one possible stress is to change the
temperature of the reaction at
equilibrium
as an example let's look at the
hypothetical reaction where gas
a turns into gas b delta h for this
reaction
is less than zero which tells us this is
an exothermic reaction
and for an exothermic reaction heat is
given off heat is released
therefore we can go ahead and write plus
heat on the product side
let's say that our hypothetical reaction
is at equilibrium
and then we change the temperature so
we're going to increase
the temperature according to the shot
latest principle the net reaction is
going to go in the direction that
decreases the stress
and if we treat heat if we if we treat
heat like a product
and we've increased the temperature it's
as if we've increased the amount of one
of our products and therefore the net
reaction is going to shift to the left
to
decrease a product let's use particulate
diagrams and the reaction quotient q
to explain what's going on when we
increase the temperature on a reaction
at equilibrium the first particular
diagram shows the reaction at
equilibrium and let's prove that by
calculating qc
at this moment in time we can get the
expression for the reaction quotient qc
by looking at the balanced equation
so we have coefficients of one in front
of a and in front of b
therefore q c is equal to the
concentration of b to the first power
divided by the concentration of a
also to the first power to find the
concentration of b
we know that b is represented by blue
spheres so there are one two
three blue spheres and if each sphere
represents 0.1 moles of a substance
3 times 0.1 is equal to 0.3 moles of b
and if the volumes equal to 1.0 liter
0.3 divided by 1.0 liter is 0.3 molar
so the concentration of b is equal to
0.3
molar there are also three particles
of a therefore the concentration of a is
also equal to 0.3 molar
0.3 divided by 0.3 is equal to 1 so qc
at this moment of time is equal to 1.
kc for this reaction is equal to 1 at 25
degrees
celsius so qc is equal to kc
and when qc is equal to kc the reaction
is
at equilibrium so for this first
particulate diagram
the reaction's at equilibrium next we
introduce the stress to the reaction
at equilibrium and the stress is an
increase
in the temperature in general for an
exothermic reaction
increasing the temperature lowers the
value for the equilibrium constant
so for this hypothetical reaction at 25
degrees celsius kc
is equal to 1 but since we've increased
the temperature
the the value for the equilibrium
constant is going to decrease so let's
say it goes to
0.5 if we increase the temperature to
30 degrees celsius
so if we calculate qc for our second
particulate diagram
we still have three blues and three reds
and the volume is still the same
therefore
qc is still equal to one
but the difference is kc has now changed
so qc is not
equal to kc so we are not at
equilibrium and in this case qc
is greater than kc because qc is equal
to 1 and kc is equal to 0.5
and when qc is greater than kc
there are too many products and not
enough reactants
and therefore the net reaction goes
to the left when the net reaction goes
to the left
we're going to have b turn into a
so we should see one blue sphere turn
into
one red sphere so if we have three blues
and three reds and one blue turns into a
red
that gives us only two blues and four
reds now
so when we calculate qc for our third
particular diagram the concentration of
b would be 0.2 molar and the
concentration of a
would be 0.4 molar so 0.2 divided by
0.4 is equal to 0.5
well kc is also equal to 0.5
therefore qc is equal to kc
and the reaction is at equilibrium
and when a reaction is at equilibrium
the concentrations of reactants and
products
are constant let's go back to our
hypothetical reaction at equilibrium
but this time we're going to decrease
the temperature
if we treat heat like a product
decreasing the temperature is like
decreasing the amount of one of the
products therefore the net reaction will
go to the right
to make more product if we approach this
problem by thinking about the reaction
quotient q
for an exothermic reaction a decrease in
temperature
in general causes an increase in the
equilibrium constant
and if the equilibrium constant
increases then q
would be less than k and when q is less
than k
the net reaction goes to the right
the net reaction would continue to go to
the right until q is equal to k
and equilibrium has been reestablished
next let's look at an endothermic
reaction where delta h
is greater than zero when six water
molecules complex to a cobalt two plus
ion the resulting complex ion is pink in
color
and when four chloride anions complex to
a cobalt two plus
ion the resulting complex ion is blue
in color when the pink ion reacts with
four chloride anions
the blue ion is formed and since this
reaction is endothermic we can put
heat on the reactant side
we're going to use these particulate
diagrams down here to help us understand
what happens to an endothermic reaction
at
equilibrium when the temperature changes
however these drawings aren't designed
to be completely accurate for this
particular reaction they're just to help
us
understand what color we would see for
example let's say that this
middle particulate diagram represents
the reaction at
equilibrium and if there are decent
amounts of both the blue ion
and the pink ion at equilibrium the
resulting
equilibrium mixture so this is an
aqueous solution
would appear to be purple or violet
if we were to increase the temperature
for this endothermic reaction we treat
heat
like a reactant so increasing the
temperature is like
increasing the amount of a reactant and
therefore the net reaction
will shift to the right to get rid of
some of that reactant
when the net reaction goes to the right
we're going to increase in the amount of
blue ion
and we're going to decrease in the
amount of pink ion
therefore looking at this particulate
diagram on the right
there are now more blue ions than there
are pink ions compared to our
equilibrium mixture in the middle
therefore for this third particular
diagram the resulting aqueous solution
is going to look blue if we think about
this using
q in general for an endothermic reaction
an increase in temperature causes an
increase in the equilibrium constant k
and if k increases then the
the reaction quotient q is less than k
and when q is less than k the net
reaction goes
to the right now let's go back to the
middle particular diagram and so there
are reactions at equilibrium and this
time we're going to
decrease the temperature if we treat
heat as a reactant
and we decrease the temperature it's
like we're decreasing one of our
reactants therefore the net reaction
will shift to the left to make
more of our reactant and when the net
reaction goes to the left we're going to
decrease in the amount of the blue ion
we're going to increase in the amount of
the pink ion so
when we compare the middle particulate
diagram to the one on the left
and then on the left there's a lot more
of the pink ion
than there is of the blue ion therefore
the overall
solution the overall aqueous solution is
going to appear
pink if we think about what's happening
using q
for an endothermic reaction in general
when you decrease the temperature you
decrease the equilibrium constant
and if the equilibrium constant
decreases
now q would be greater than k which
means too many products and not enough
reactants therefore the net reaction
would go to the left
let's go back to our exothermic reaction
at this time let's pretend like we're
starting with only a
so we start with only a and we have none
of b and our goal is to make as much b
as we possibly can
and to do it as fast as possible one way
to increase the rate of a reaction would
be to
increase the temperature however for an
exothermic reaction
increasing the temperature decreases the
equilibrium constant k
and if you decrease the equilibrium
constant k you would decrease the amount
of
b that you would have when you reach
equilibrium
so we can't run our hypothetical
reaction at too high of a temperature
because that would decrease the
equilibrium constant
so instead to speed up the rate of the
reaction we could add
a catalyst
look at a graph of concentration of b
versus time
and we're going to start with this blue
curve here which represents
the the hypothetical reaction without a
catalyst so the uncatalyzed reaction
when time is equal to zero the
concentration of b is zero because we
start with only
a and as a turns into b the
concentration of b
increases over time and eventually the
concentration of b
becomes constant and when the
concentration of b becomes
constant the reaction reaches
equilibrium so this
this dotted line here represents the
concentration of b
at equilibrium the yellow line
represents the reaction
with a catalyst added so once again
we're starting with only a
so when time is equal to zero the
concentration of b is equal to zero
and as time increases a turns into b so
the concentration of b
increases and eventually the
concentration of b
becomes constant and the reaction
reaches equilibrium
notice that the reaction reached
equilibrium much faster with the
addition of the catalyst
than it did without the catalyst so the
addition of a catalyst
allows a reaction to to reach
equilibrium faster
however notice that the final
equilibrium concentration of
b is the same for both the uncatalyzed
reaction and the catalyzed reaction
therefore the addition of a catalyst
does not change the composition
of the equilibrium mixture and that's
because the catalyst speeds up
both the forward reaction and the
reverse reaction
but the rates are still equal and since
the rates are equal there's no change in
the composition of the equilibrium
mixture